in our series i on earth we are looking
at how climate change is contributing
to these severe wildfires take a look at
federal satellite footage this is from
noaa and it shows
smoke billowing from california and
oregon extending far over the pacific
ocean
several of the california fire started
when a so-called lightning
siege with nearly 12 thousand strikes in
a week hit the state last month cbs news
meteorologist and climate specialist
jeff beradelli joins us now jeff good
morning to you
hard to overstate how extreme this fire
season has been three out of four
three out of the four largest fires to
ever ignite in california are
burning right now what's going on here
so we have a short-term reason for this
and then there's a long-term reason for
this the short-term reason is we just
had
two unprecedented heat waves back to
back
some of the hottest temperatures ever
experienced in the southwest and in
california
both of them basically unprecedented
made worse
by climate change and that really dries
out the foliage it dries out the brush
it dries out the trees
on top of that it's been very dry there
hasn't been much rain
and we have a bad drought in most of the
west and especially
in places like oregon that's the
short-term reason
the long-term reason is mostly climate
change yes there's a build-up of brush
that's for sure
but climate change is making things
worse because over the course of the
past
few decades air temperatures in the west
have risen a couple of degrees to a few
degrees depending upon where you are
what that does is it adds energy and
heat to the atmosphere
that dries out the brush it dries out
the atmosphere it causes a moisture gap
or moisture
deficit in the atmosphere and research
shows that that moisture deficit can
explain
almost all of the increase in burned
area since the 1970s and so because of
that since the 1970s
we've seen an increase five times in
burned area in california
fire season is two to three months
longer than it was
and also 17 of the 20 worst fires have
burned
since 2000. and we have a graphic to
show you which is really amazing it
shows you
in the yellow bars the burned area from
each and every year
over the past several years notice what
has happened in the year
2020 that is off the charts and that's
because also we've seen
a rise in temperatures so there's a
direct correlation between climate
change
and burned area if you look at that
chart we're only halfway through
2020. wow we're seeing a lot of things
we've never seen before jeff one of
those things is these pictures out of
san francisco the bay area
it looked like a scene from blade runner
really apocalyptic looking kind of an
orange haze no
filter at all what was causing that
so it's not climate change and we hope
and we think it's not the apocalypse
right
but what it is is very similar to
sunrise and sunset
when light has to go through a wide part
of the atmosphere it gets scattered a
lot more so what happened
in places like san francisco is for
weeks on end
the smoke was not blowing into town now
it's blowing into town and the air
became stagnant
stagnant it got trapped and what happens
is during sunrise and sunset the light
shines through
and it gets scattered and it reveals the
spectrum of colors
and the last of those colors is red and
orange so if you have thick enough smoke
thick enough pollution
it will scatter and your eye will only
see the reds and the orange so just like
sunrise and sunset when it's really
smoky
it has kind of the same effect and it
turns the sky orange it does make for a
memorable picture is there anything that
people can do
out west right now to improve the
situation that they're living through
you know everybody can do something but
even you know one person
a group of people or even a region like
the west can't do it alone
this is a global problem we need
systemic collective
solutions but here's the good news this
actually is an opportunity for us to
create a better
life for ourselves we need to throw
every solution and
the whole kitchen sink at this the good
news is we know what the problem is
we know what the solution is and now we
have the technology for it
renewable energy is becoming cheaper
than fossil fuels we have to
lessen our addiction to fossil fuels in
order to combat this problem
the good news is because it's becoming
cheaper and economically feasible
and it's actually better for the economy
by the way it's creating tons of jobs
right now the number one
and number three jobs occupations growth
are solar and wind technician in america
so it's creating great american jobs and
because the economy is moving in that
direction
i think we should seize on this as an
opportunity that's definitely something
to keep in mind jeff thank you very much